so the bellagio conservatory and
botanical garden is celebrating
the year of the ox the season of love
lunar new year presentation
it is now on display it is absolutely
beautiful and bianca holman is there
live for us with a look at that good
morning bianca hey good morning alex it
is so
tranquil here at the bellagio and they
never cease to amaze us they're always
changing five times a year they change
this display so now
it's time for the year of the ox it's a
celebrating the lunar you new year
and i'm joined by leslie who's the
manager so i understand everything in
here is meticulously chosen by an expert
yes so each year we enlist the
assistance of a feng shui expert
to ensure that we have good placement
positive flow of chi
right down to the walkway and how you
enter yeah and so as we walk around tell
us what people will experience what
would they walk away from this
a new exhibit with a new sense of what
tell me
we're hoping that everyone leaves with a
little more serenity in their heart than
maybe they came in with
that is where we find our reward is
seeing the reaction from people
so each bed has a different
element a different feel if you will
so when you first enter you'll see
overhead the jade medallions
we use cutting edge technology those are
actually 3d printed
and the color is embedded in them so
that it looks like actual jade
in asian culture they say that gold is
precious
but jade is priceless incredible
incredible and give me the numbers
because
you know even though of course all
industries have been impacted by covet i
know you know
this has impacted you all as far as
getting certain
flowers and things like that to make
these creations but give us the numbers
well mother nature gives us a bounty to
choose from so that's always on our side
so during the course of our ten week
show we will feature over
sixty three 000 plants and cut flowers
for people to enjoy
wonderful so this is going on till when
give us the date can people start they
can come now i mean you can you don't
have to wait
but you can come right now enjoy lunch
here at the bellagio bring your kids
talk about the lunar new year yeah or
bring a date because it's also a little
sultry in the evening too as well so
give us uh when does this run till
this runs through march 6th and then we
will transition
to spring all right so you know this is
always changing you want to get in here
before march 6 to check out this
wonderful
lunar new year display season of love
gonna send it back to you guys in the
studio
oh that's so beautiful and bianca what a
good idea for valentine's day
if you're looking for an idea if you
haven't thought about an idea
that is a good one yeah all right thank
you so much